[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous avons parlé du nucléaire
le nucléaire est il une chance pour
l'europe tous plaident pour un
développement d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire dans le monde naturellement en
europe et particulièrement en france les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes le
nucléaire est à l'origine de 10% de la
production mondiale d'électricité de 26%
au sein de l'union européenne est de 70%
en france d'électro nucléaire est une
énergie pilotable c'est-à-dire
disponibles quels que soient les
conditions atmosphériques
décarbonés pour l'essentiel ce qui est
précieux dans le cas de la transition
énergétique de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et dont le coût
demeure compétitive par rapport aux
coûts des autres énergies notamment des
énergies renouvelables par ailleurs au
regard de nos modes de vie et du progrès
des technologies notamment numériques
nous vivons une ère exceptionnelle de
mobilité des personnes des biens des
services et des territoires etc mobilité
feront passer à échéance d'aujourd'hui à
2050 la part de l'électricité au sein du
bouquet électronique de 25% à 55 % il
faudra bien trouver des énergies propres
pour faire face à la demande parmi elles
le nucléaire les énergies renouvelables
à savoir celles qui proviennent de
l'hydraulique du solaire de l'éolien de
la biomasse seul ombre au tableau du
nucléaire la question des déchets
nucléaires notamment des déchets à très
hauts toxicité et de très longue durée
et qui font l'objet de technique
d'enfouissement par ailleurs les deux
années de crise sanitaire et la guerre
en ukraine ces deux événements prix sans
relation de cause à effet est-ce que
ceux des ces deux événements nous ont
montré là que la question de l'énergie
d'une énergie propre est disponible
incluant le nucléaire et la sécurisation
de l'approvisionnement énergétique et
massez question préoccupe et l'ensemble
des citoyens pour en parler je vous
présente mes invités alors xavier ursat
vous êtes directeur ingénierie et
nouveau nucléaire à edf
brice lalonde vous êtes ancien ministre
de la transition écologique mais à votre
époque quand vous étiez mini ça
s'appelait pas transition écologique je
crois que c'était directement un
ministère de l'écologie nord
d'environnement de l'environnement et
qu'on s'occupait des humains voilà très
bien claude imauven vous êtes président
doha nos jacques percebois vous êtes
professeur des universités économistes
[Musique]
vous venez de voir une citation
d'emmanuel macro nous allons d'abord
évoqué le nucléaire en france le
président de la république emmanuel
macron qui a été réélu en avril 2022
pour un second mandat a annoncé un plan
de relance du nucléaire à la fois la
construction de nouveaux nucléaire est
le prolongement de la durée de vie des
réacteurs existants au delà de 50 ans
c'est un défi industriel considérable
pour edf et l'ensemble de la filière
nucléaire française
question que l'on se pose est vous êtes
prêt à relever ce défi à réussir ce
challenge et vous pouvez nous dire
concrètement comment cela se prépare
xavier oui j'irai d'abord que nous avons
été très très heureux en fait entendre
ce discours du président de la
république et qui il faut le rappeler a
finalement positionner l'enjeu de la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et l'atteinte de la trajectoire
bas carbone de la france ainsi que les
enjeux de souveraineté comme les deux
enjeux clés de la politique énergétique
à moyen et à long terme il faut
commencer peut être par là et donc en
exprimant que les solutions sont dans
l'économie des économies d'énergie le
développement du renouvelable est une
véritable politique nucléaire dans mon
esprit déjà scellé 3 qu'il faut qu'il
faut envisager et en effet cette
politique nucléaire passe par la
prolongation à chaque fois que les
conditions de sûreté seront réunis des
réacteurs existants et par la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs en
france il l'a exprimé lui-même 6 pers
vers 2 exactement quel cousins germains
on en reparlera peut-être dans un
premier temps et peut être étudiée donc
non construites supplémentaire pour
aller jusqu'à 14 dans l'est dans les 20
prochaines années la filière en fait
travaille sur ces sujets là l'ensemble
des donneurs de la filière et l'ensemble
des industriels de la filière depuis
plusieurs années après une réussite
extraordinaire qui était la construction
du parc nucléaire français dans les
années 70 80 90 la construction de
l'ensemble des usines du du cycle aussi
une époque qui était une véritable
époque industrielle on s'est mis à faire
un peu plus des réacteurs au compte
gouttes en réfléchissant beaucoup avant
d'agir et ça a été une vraie difficulté
dans les années 90 et les années et les
années 2000 ce qui a conduit d'ailleurs
certains projets à rencontrer des
difficultés sur ces difficultés la
filière française edf ont bâti un retour
d'expérience et on bâtit une nouvelle
cohésion avec d'ailleurs la création
d'un syndicat professionnel qui fédère
la filière qui font que je crois
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts nous
sommes prêts mais avec des gros enjeu
devant nous qu'est-ce que l'entrée dans
leurs détails voilà mais quand vous
dites vous êtes prêts ça veut dire que
edf avec les autres entreprises de la
filière sont prêts à relever ce défi
aujourd'hui exactement nous avons défini
le modèle que nous souhaitons construire
il est validé par l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire nous avons une trajectoire des
ressources qui sont à engager des
capacités industrielles qui sont engagés
pour le construire en france nous avons
retour d'expérience complet en fait des
premiers projets dont je dirais vraiment
tenir les délais des prochains projets
qui est probablement l'objectif numéro 1
le reste j'ai envie de dire on suivra et
puis nous sommes en train vraiment de
créer cette cohésion industriel au sein
de la filière qui me fait dire que nous
sommes prêts à relever ce défi vous
diriez la même chose claudie mauvais
en précisant le rôle
doha nos sûr dans ce mécano nucléaire
tout à fait je dirais la même chose
gérer que sous le leadership d'edf le la
filière est complètement mobilisé ça
signifie être conscient de ses
faiblesses de voir comment les comment
les paliers
mais je crois que ces choses sont
claires tout le monde va dans la même
direction c'est vrai aussi que pour ce
qui est du combustible nous avons
peut-être eu la chance d'avoir moins d'à
coups puisqu'on a toujours continué à
exploiter de l'uranium à le convertir à
l'enrichir et un recyclé donc on a eu
moins d'un coup ce qui signifie pas
qu'on n'est pas des défis devant nous et
qui faillit suivre ce set cette montée
donc je dirais que la spécificité de la
france en ce qui concerne bien entendu
on a un opérateur très important et je
crois que ses clés mais pour le
combustible la spécificité c'est qu'on a
un opérateur qui maîtrise l'ensemble de
la chaîne depuis la mine jusqu'au
recyclage c'est une particularité
française bien donc là on va essayer de
prolonger cette discussion avec vos
brice lalonde
le contexte actuel de relance du
nucléaire est quand même différent quoi
qu'on dise de ce qu'il était à l'époque
des années 70 avec ce qu'on a appelé le
programme messmer du nom de pierre
messmer qui en a qui était à l'époque
ministre du général de gaulle l'élan
industriel n'est pas le même aujourd'hui
il y a une certaine méfiance du public
il y a eu des accidents de tchernobyl et
fukushima
il y a le coût élevé du nouveau
nucléaire tout facteur à prendre en
considération à la fois par les pouvoirs
publics l'industrie les banques
l'opinion publique alors à vous je
poserai la la même question mais pas en
termes de défis industriels mais de défi
écologique et citoyen est ce qu'on est
prêt à ce niveau-là à cette nouvelle
aventure à ce défi industriel d'un
nucléaire
venant
réindustrialiser en quelque sorte la
france depuis les années 90 le problème
écologique numéro un sept changements
climatiques ça ne l'était pas où c'était
pas on ne le savait pas avant des années
car depuis alors si le problème numéro
un c'est le changement climatique ça
veut dire que l'adversaire sur les
combustibles fossiles les méchants c'est
le pétrole le charbon et c'est le gaz
naturel gaz naturel d'ailleurs qui fait
semblant d'être bon tant qu' on est dans
une improbable m difficile en ce moment
et la manière de lutter contre les
combustibles fossiles c'est
d'électrifier l'électrification
l'électricité va jouer un rôle
absolument fondamental
il en faudra plus on va en parler et
contrairement à ce que les gens pensent
ça c'est là peut-être la plus grande
difficulté c'est que décarbonée c'est
une aventure industrielle et ça coûte
beaucoup d'énergie contrairement à ce
que les gens pensent les gens nous
disaient on va construire de moins en
moins ça va être formidable puis comme
ça on va régler improbable pas du tout
il faut plus d'énergie parce qu'il faut
produire d'électricité ça n'existe pas
dans la nature pour la produire pour
produire de l'hydrogène pour produire
des carburants de synthèse tout ça les
électrolyseurs les batteries échoué rezé
qui les battent il faut chercher les
métaux faute et externes et raffinée
tout ça c'est une aventure elle nouvelle
donc c'est une période nouvelle et en
effet il faut de l'énergie décarbonée et
le nucléaire est là donc le nu avec les
autres sources d'énergie il est là on en
a besoin donc il faut s'en servir et sur
le plan citoyen a alors là manifestement
il ya une discussion à voir mais ça
commence moi je dois bien mes amis à moi
écolo il n'aime pas le nucléaire mais
ils se disent bon bah peut-être que
pendant encore un certain temps on en a
encore besoin et donc la discussion va
s'organiser comme ça est ce que le
nucléaire est une énergie de transition
est ce qu'au contraire ça peut
s'améliorer le nucléaire vous parlez des
déchets tout à l'heure moi j'ai des tas
d'idées sont les défis alors c'est mon
idée à moi dire que ce qu'on va rentrer
dans le détail mais sur la pertinence
citoyenne vous pensez qu'il ya du
travail à faire c'est à dire il veut
face à ce nouveau défi industriel il ya
besoin d'une communication citoyenne
très forte où ça va de pair les gens
vont suivre autour ce que le la guerre
en ukraine la dépendance de l'allemagne
vis-à-vis du gaz russe c'est quand même
une leçon de choses extraordinaires
parce que pendant très longtemps les
écologistes les antinucléaires disait
mais on n'a qu'à faire les renouvelables
plus le gaz sah de gaz va être le bas
capcom on dit le suppléant de
l'intermittence n'avait pas du tout et
le gaz en plus de ça le gaz c'est assez
dangereux le gaz il fait semblant d'être
meilleur que le charbon mais si à 3% de
fuite il est pire que charbon or les
fuites y en a beaucoup et donc si vous
voulez le gaz il faut se méfier beaucoup
et donc quand le veuille ou non surtout
dans un pays qui a une tradition
nucléaire à savoir faire du théâtre pàp
quand même on va pas tous les recours
mettent tout ça aux oubliettes c'est
très utile au contraire profitons-en
alors jacques percebois vous êtes un
économiste de l'énergie nous poserait la
même question mais à travers la
pertinence économique
est ce qu'il ya une pertinence
économique à aller vers le choix du
nucléaire va la réponse est oui d'abord
le nucléaire actuelle il est compétitif
d'ailleurs c'est un des facteurs qui
permet une certaine stabilité du prix de
l'électricité en france
parce qu'il est largement amortis donc à
l'heure actuelle les centrales qui
fonctionnent sont des centrales
compétitive largement le duc lai
renouveau est un peu plus cher alors si
on prend évidemment flamanville il est
nettement plus cher mais c'est une tête
de série et c'est logique tout têtes de
série coûtent cher à partir du moment où
on profite d'économies d'échelle c'est à
dire qu'on en fait plusieurs on estime
qu'avec les se perd 2 le programme et le
projet de six ou huit paires de et 14 au
total si on suit et ce qui était dit à
belfort eh bien ça doit permettre
d'avoir un nucléaire qui sera compétitif
avec avec les substituts alors il faut
insister sur deux choses quand on parle
du coût du mégawattheure on va rentrer
dans le détail mais sur la la pertinence
le choix d'aller vers le nucléaire c'est
à la fois une pertinence industriel
écologique citoyenne et économique donc
leur économique oui surtout si on tient
compte du fait que les substituts sont
intermittents qu'il faut prévoir donc ce
qu'on appelle les coûts système terre
les externalités lié à l'intermittence
alors ils ont le rapport de rte qui a
étudié très très bien différents
scénarios alors dans l'aspect
faisabilité dans l'aspect économique
très bien alors on va essayer d'aller un
peu plus loin problème d'arithmétique en
2050 il est prévu 50% en france
d'électricité d'origine nucléaire on est
aujourd'hui à 70% de telle manière à
faire place à 50% d'énergies
renouvelables
mais du fait des mobilités la part de
l'électricité dans le mix énergétique va
doubler elle va passer à 55 % dans ce
contexte comment on va programmer un
parc nucléaire français pour satisfaire
les nouveaux besoins est ce que tout ça
émouvant tout ça émouvant en fait je
pense qu'il faut il faut s'attacher à
voir ce qu'on veut atteindre et quels
sont les moyens que nous avons à notre
disposition
et puis se dire qu'on va être dans un
mécanisme qu'il faudra adapter au fur et
à mesure je crois que c'est c'est
extrêmement important c'est toujours
intéressant de j'entends les gens dire
on va consommer exactement ce temps
d'énergie en 2050 il faudra qu'ils et
elles part de nucléaire d'éolien et
cetera la vérité c'est qu'il va falloir
s'adapter
peinture alors quels sont les enjeux les
enjeux c'est d'être dans une trajectoire
bas carbone et que finalement le bouquet
énergétique français sur le plus faible
possible en émissions de co2 et
multiples gaz à effet de serre en 2050
pour y arriver le premier levier c'est
d'électrifier notre économie donc
d'électrifier tous les processus dans
les entreprises avoir le maximum
d'équipements électriques dans les
maisons et donc en effet vous l'avez
différents sorte que l'électricité qui
représentent 25 % de la consommation
d'énergie de la france représente plutôt
à peu près 50% de en 2050 qui fait que
même si on fait ici ou là des économies
d'énergie et 50% en 2050 ça fera
beaucoup plus que les 25% en 2020 il
comprit en nucléaire est alors j'y viens
quels sont les trois leviers notre
disposition cependant la
fondamentalement trois dans le domaine
je parle dans le domaine des énergies
bas carbone ensuite il y aura des
leviers hydrogène des leviers
autres mais dans la production directe
d'électricité faire du renouvelable
prolonger les réacteurs existants
construire de nouveaux réacteurs n'ont
pas tellement d'autres leviers faire des
économies d'énergie et évidemment je les
dis faire des économies d'énergie bon il
faut absolument faire du renouvelable
enfin moi je pense que aujourd'hui on
est sur eux sur un rythme de progression
du renouvelable si on regarde les
dernières années qui est insuffisant par
rapport à la trajectoire que que nous
souhaitons il en faut d'autant plus que
c'est un des moyens qu'on peut rentrer
quand même assez vite sur le marché il
faut prolonger les réacteurs lancés
d'ailleurs la décision qui voient le
moindre délai entre la prise de décision
et les faits ça a effectivement dans le
domaine du bas carbone tout ce qui est
massif est assez long sauf
qu'actuellement il ya beaucoup de
centrales qui sont arrêtés à c'est un
autre sujet on pourra y revenir si vous
le souhaitez mais c'est une suggestion
se projette dans le long terme il faut
gérer cette trajectoire des réacteurs en
service et puis il faut en construire de
nouveaux
nos perceptions à edf c'est qu'il
fallait déjà lancé une série de 6 parce
que c'est là que nous avons en effet
industrielle est en effet en étudier
assez rapidement jusqu'à 14 parce que 14
réacteurs mis en service d'ici 2040 de
45 2050 à vous fait déjà cédé recteur
delà de la classe super d'ondés le pr2
ça fait quand même une quantité
d'énergie qui est déjà significative aux
côtés du renouvelable qui va se
construire aux côtés des réacteurs que
nous allons prolonger et je pense qu'il
faudra régulièrement révisé nos
trajectoires se dire comment il évolue
vraiment là formation comme en arrivant
nous a vraiment développé du
renouvelable quels sont les réacteurs
que nous avons réussi à prendre a
prolongé à quelle vitesse nous
construisons les nouveaux réacteurs et
il faudra appuyer sur ces différentes
touches du piano la politique
énergétique française pour moi c'est un
c'est un morceau de musique il va
falloir jouer sur un piano qu'il ya
c'est qu' à ces différentes touches des
économies d'énergie de la progression du
renouvelable de l'évolution de la
consommation de la preuve la
prolongation du nucléaire existant et de
la construction du nouveau nucléaire il
faut lancer tout cela il faut lancer à
bon rythme parce que si vous calculez
je dirais le bénéfice d'avoir atteint
votre objectif notre objectif bas
carbone est votre objectif
d'indépendance énergétique par rapport
au risque d'avoir mégoter sur l'un ou
l'autre des sujets et de se retrouver
sans solution en fait le rapport
bénéfices risques est sans commune
mesure que ce soit au plan
environnemental où que ce soit au plan
des intérêts industriels et économiques
de l'om est alors plaints du mauvais
vous êtes d'accord avec ce scénario et à
votre avis en 2050 il faudra t'il plus
que ses six plus huit nouveaux réacteurs
dans la mesure où la produit la
production d'électricité sera d' doubla
par rapport à ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
est ce qu'à votre avis cette part de
nucléaire va augmenter encore une fois
vous aviez ça parfaitement planté le
décor c'est ça va être une partition qui
va s'écrire avec le mouvement parce qu'
on a bien vu que les clés les
projections de consommation
d'électricité qui avait notamment sous
tendu la précédente ppe ça s'avère
dépassé donc que sera la consommation du
pays connaîtra-t-on d'autres crises leur
accélération en sais rien il faut rester
très flexible et je crois que ça a été
dit de manière très clairement économie
d économiser l'énergie dans une vie
antérieure je me méfie beaucoup atelier
quand j'étais chez saint gobain et
deuxièmement
poussé le renouvelable partout où on
peut le faire et ensuite accéléré sur le
nucléaire mais
vous verrez qu'il ya un problème de
délai les centrales que l'on a décidé
aujourd'hui ne verront pas le jour avant
certain temps vous avez dit 2035 2040 45
mètres 50 pour les dernières entre temps
il va falloir continuer à fonctionner
avec cette énergie décarbonée que le
nucléaire donc prolonger la durée de vie
donc peut-être que ça me fera pas assez
mais en tout cas il faut écrire la
partition au fur à mesure que se
présente les enjeux nous en pensée brise
sur la trajectoire ou la voyez comme
elle a été elle est décrite par les
industriels nous vous pensez que la boj
désert comme eux mais je pense que
idéalement il faudrait 30 p r en 2050
idéalement mais je ne pense pas qu'on
que l'appareil industriel soit capable
de construire en temps utile que et la
difficulté pour pouvoir modifier
pourquoi vous dites qu'il faut 30 parce
que la consommation parce qu'il faut
assurer la consommation d'énergie et
d'électricité c'est aussi simple que ça
parce que les renouvelables ne suffiront
pas un monde et que même s'ils auront
leurs 24 ainsi même si on prolonge la
durée de vie s'il ya des mayas il ya un
phasage compliqué donc que je laisse aux
experts le soin de préciser si vous
voulez même on voit bien qu'il dit de
regarder les difficultés les centrales
elle commence un peu à vieillir on
découvre qu'il ya des fissures on a du
mal à savoir si on a vraiment ou pas
parce que les ultrasons c'est pas si
simple que ça tout ça c'est compliqué
bon donc main il faut assurer et puis si
on peut exporter de l'électricité c'est
pas plus mal semble-t-il parce que
c'était une grande force aussi de notre
pays doit exporter l'électricité
la question de la souveraineté et du
coup ce sont des questions aussi
extrêmement importante bon alors
maintenant pour le reste c'est pas si
simple parce qu'on a des instructions
contradictoires ni les renouvelables le
solaire c'est magnifique de salaire il
ya une mieux que le salaire franchement
l'éolien outils à non les olé c'est
moins bien mais le solaire c'est
formidable ça pas il faut de la place
faut du foncier alors donc c'est très
très compliqué on en a pas tellement il
faut lutter contre l'artificialisation
ça fait partie aussi du soit écologique
vers la crispation sur l'éolien vous en
pensez quoi alors moi aussi j'ai mon
petit point de vue c'est que les
éoliennes les petites éoliennes de
village ou deux ça me suffit chez moi
c'était très bien mais maintenant on a
des monstres absolument gigantesque
c'est très très différent quoi donc si
vous voilà une éolienne qui fait 10
mégawatts juste devant vous quand vous
avez votre petite maison au bord de la
mer vous vous dites
c'était pas comme ça quand j'ai acheté
cette maison un bon voilà donc vous êtes
en train de vous dire il ya un
gigantesque il ya une machine
industrielle gigantesque en face de moi
c'est comme une centaine nucléaire sauf
que me elle s'arrête quand ya pas de
vent mais ça marche peut-être moins bien
elle prend plus de place l abîme mais
elle tue quelques sous à zoé sur souris
en fait c'est donc c'est très bien les
yolaine il en faut évidemment ça donne
de la puissance mais au départ ne soit
des yvelines c'était parce qu'on ne
voulait pas de nucléaire il faut le dire
carrément que je me souviens très bien
c'était ça au départ on ne veut des
grosses éoliennes de puissance parce
qu'autrement on n'arrivera pas à
remplacer les entendu terre c'était ça
au départ et dans les pays qui sont qui
sont les champions des éoliennes sont
des pays qui n'aime pas nucléaire et
c'est vrai que le matériel de l'éolienne
n'est pas recyclable alors les pales ne
le sont pas mais ça sera peut-être on a
vu tout ça ces images où l'on voit les
enterrer les éoliennes les pales des
éoliennes ensuite il ya des aimants il
ya des problèmes de métaux bon entre
nous soit dit ça marche quand même ça
marche et plus elles sont grandes et
puissantes
offshore comme on dit en mer et les
flottante à la limite c'est pas un
problème ouais et alors multiplions les
flottante alors je perds ce mois le
nucléaire défis industriels défi
technologique mais défi financier je
voulais avec vous voir c'était explorer
cette contradiction grâce au nucléaire
en france nous produisons moindre coût
de l'électricité
du moins si nous nous comparons à nos
voisins notamment aux allemands mais
cette électricité est vendu quasiment à
son prix de revient que cela profite aux
usagers c'est très bien c'est parfait
mais ce que c'est économiquement viable
pour un projet industriel nucléaire et
qu'en est il du coût de revient plus
élevé que pour le nouveau nucléaire la
grande question c'est comment ça va être
financée et donc le choix du mode de
financement un impact direct sur le prix
de revient donc tout va dépendre du taux
d'intérêt qui sera qui sera pris en
compte quand on regarde le le plan
messmer est bien le financement s'est
fait dans de très bonnes conditions
financières et df s'endetter notamment
sur le marché américain mais dans de
bonnes conditions hélas les simulations
montrent que suivant le plan de
financement suivant la halle la façon
dont le nucléaire et financer et bien le
prix de revient peut être plus ou moins
élevé alors plusieurs projets sont
possibles on le voit d'ailleurs avec
l'expérience anglaise on peut avoir des
systèmes furet de contrat pour
différents c'est à dire qu'on garantie à
un prix de revient en quelque sorte un
prix de vente sur longue période pour le
nucléaire et si le prix auquel le
nucléaire est vendu sur le marché de
gros et est inférieur et bien l'état
verse la différence si le prix est
supérieur c'est l'opérateur qui reverse
la différence on peut aussi financer le
projet nucléaire comme on finance les
réseaux électriques c'est d'ailleurs un
projet à l'heure actuelle qui consiste à
dire il faut utiliser le même mécanisme
pour financer les projets nucléaires que
pour financer le réseau de transport ou
le réseau de distribution d'électricité
auquel cas c'est ce qu'on appelle un
coast plus on aux finances au fil de
l'eau en quelque sorte les programmes
donc le mode de financement vais tout à
fait déterminant on va avoir besoin de
beaucoup de capitaux mais c'est vrai
aussi pour pour les renouvelables parce
que n'oublions pas que on parle beaucoup
à l'heure actuelle de de la relance du
nucléaire mais si vous regardez
général à la ppe 6 à la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie la loi
actuelle qui devrait être modifié en
2023 puisqu'il va y avoir une nouvelle
loi de programmation la loi actuelle
prévoit qu' on va construire beaucoup de
renouvelables dire le président à
belfort a annoncé qu'ils auraient
beaucoup d'investissements dans le
solaire et beaucoup d'investissements
dans l'éolien
relativement le nucléaire je dirais il
ya des projets et on est un peu en
retrait en dynamique par rapport aux
renouvelables c'est pas avec 14 e p r
que l'on va avoir 50 % d'électricité en
2050 il en faudrait beaucoup plus parce
que n'oublions hackers actuelle ils sont
prolongées jusqu'à 50 ans l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire acceptera peut-être
d'aller jusqu'à 60 ans il faut attendre
et à 60 ans en 2050 les réacteurs
actuels seront pour la plupart d'entre
eux je dirais à renouveler alors je
voudrais me tourner vers les industriels
par rapport à ce qui vient d'être dit
sur le plan financier et économique
xavière s'appelant dit mauvais en soi ce
dans les années soixante dix du siècle
passé edf était à la fois maître
d'oeuvre est maître d'ouvragé
de ce projet nucléaire aujourd'hui on
laisse entendre qu edf serait maître
d'oeuvre et qu'il y aurait une structure
qui serait maître d'ouvragé autrement
dit qui s'occuperait des investissements
est ce que vous confirmez cette chose là
où est-ce que vous pensez que edf avec
l'ensemble de la filière doit
complètement à voir si on peut dire la
maîtrise de ce défi industriel suis pas
sûr que les termes de mettre de vrais
maîtres d'ouvragé s'agissant de
l'activité dont on parle sur les plus
adaptées donc je parlerais plutôt
peut-être deux constructeurs
d'exploitants et puis peut-être un
moment il y aurait une structure de
propriétaire des installations et des
investissements a confirmé le président
de la république à belfort c'est qu'il
souhaitait que edf sur le constructeur
et soit l'exploitant c'est à dire celui
qui aura en charge les installations qui
devrait que les exploiter au mieux qui
devra
commercialisé l'électricité qui en
sortira et puis nous sommes en train de
travailler en même temps que le
financement la question de la propriété
le dire et cette question là en fait
c'est une question un peu théorique pour
les pour les français edf va participer
au financement l'état va participer au
financement il faut qu'on voie comment
on optimise tout ça et finalement dans
quelle société seront logés les actifs
mais ce qui est important c'est qu'ils
construit parce que c'est là que se joue
l'enjeu industriel qui exploite parce
que c'est là que se joue l'enjeu de
sûreté de commercialisation partout en
france à un coût efficace je vais
compléter juste si je puis me permettre
que vient de dire l'acteur se bat il
faut avoir en tête une chose
on est très heureux de parler et ça
rejoint ce que disait priestland tout à
l'heure on est tous d'accord pour dire
il faut aller vers moins de co2 et un
vrai impact dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique
il faut que nous soyons tous soucieux en
particulier dans nos vieux pays
européens de l'indépendance énergétique
dont la souveraineté énergétique ça
passe
tout le temps par des projets qui sont
de très grande intensité capitalistique
c'est-à-dire qui coûte très cher au
début pendant qu on les construit qui
coûte finalement en revanche pas si cher
que ça pendant qu'on pendant qu'on les
exploite sauf que à ce moment là faut
rembourser l'argent qu'on a donc on a
dépensé pour les construire on est
toujours sur du très long terme on eu
d'écart boudera pas une économie où on
ne rendra pas souveraine une économie à
coups de politique qui changerait tous
les trois ou tous les cinq ans ça ça
n'existe pas et donc je ne dirai rien là
dedans a besoin de temps long et c'est
vrai dans le renouvelable quel que soit
le renouvelable c'est vrai dans le c'est
vrai dans le soft peut-être pour le
solaire à petite échelle mais même pour
le solaire à grande échelle c'est vrai
et pour le nucléaire a fortiori et ça il
faut l'avoir en tête parce que dans nos
sociétés qui ont toujours un bel
engouement sur les beaux objectifs
décarbonation lutte contre le changement
climatique indépendance énergétique est
quand même un corollaire c'est constance
dans les engagements visibilité
durabilité des décisions ça c'est non
mais ça c'est quelque chose je crois de
de tout à fait fondamental à avoir en
tête parce qu'on aime bien prendre
l'aventage ambulants se dire mais
maintenant on mettra peut-être en cause
des choses régulièrement ce n'est pas
possible on décarboner a aucune économie
dans le monde en changement de la vie
tous les cinq ans et ça je crois qu'il
faut l'avoir en train d'éclore du
mauvais nous devraient illustrer ce
toujours en faisant un zoom sur le sur
le combustible parce que c'est très
complémentaire de ce qui vient d'être
dit on parle d'indépendance de
souveraineté nationale si la france l'a
construite alors que la plus de mines
d'uranium sur son territoire c'est parce
que sur le temps long elle a su
développer trouver des gisements le
développer globalement de l'uranium à
peu près il 44 % des réserves estimées
sont dans l' ocde ce qu'une grosse
différence par rapport au gaz et au
pétrole mais dans le panel de production
d'eau rano on est au niger gisement que
l'on a découvert et exploité on est au
canada est ornée au kazakhstan et on
prépare déjà le
demain et après demain c'est
l'ouzbékistan et c'est la mongolie et ça
ça se décide pas en 5 ans 10 ans 20 ans
c'est une affaire de 50 ans donc ce
temps l'on sait quelque chose
d'essentiel la matière d'énergie dire
quand on a construit la hague on avait
prévu que ça allait durer au moins
jusqu'à 2040 et est dès à présent il
faut se préoccuper de ce que sera le la
le lag pour ses réacteurs qui vont venir
en production en 2040 2050 c'est à
entendre et répond juste en une phrase
moi ma préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est
pas tellement de savoir si ce sera 14 20
25 ou 30 la question aujourd'hui c'est
de lancer la filière industrielle
j'avais dit sur au moins si c'est tant
mieux si c'est au moins 14 mai de lancer
la filière industrielle et cette filière
industrielle une fois qu'elle sera
lancée elle sera capable d'accélérer et
c'est ça qui donne qui nous conte qui
compte aujourd'hui oui jacques percebois
le temps long c'est important
aujourd'hui l'électricité vendue sur un
marché le système libéralisé ray que les
prix du marché sont très volatils il ya
deux ans n'était à 40 euros le mégawatt
heure en moyenne il ya même eu des prix
négatifs le 4 avril 2022 on est monté
presque à 3000 euros le mégawattheure
aujourd'hui on est 30 200 et 300 euros
le mégawattheure dur à partir du moment
où vous avez une volatilité comme ça des
prix de marché les signaux que le marché
envoie son je dirai tout à fait
contradictoires ne permettent pas aux
industriels de faire des investissements
de long terme on n'aurait pas pu
construire le programme nucléaire du
plan messmer avec des prix aussi volatil
donc il faut une certaine stabilité
serment pour laquelle aujourd'hui il est
indispensable de modifier un peu le
système qui existe en matière de prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés européens
est ce que
ton avec l'électrification c'est aussi
l'électrification des usages ou et donc
il faut que pendant en même temps que la
production s'organise il faut que la
consommation à s'organise et ça veut
dire en deux si on veut qu'en 2050 on
soit 50% ça veut dire 1% d'augmentation
de la consommation d'électricité tous
les ans et donc on voit que ça commence
avec les véhicules des véhicules légers
mais c'est pas si facile parce que c'est
une vraie révolution à la fois pour les
constructeurs il faut mais tdd de la
recharge par tous les autoroutes les
machins tout ça c'est très très
compliqué il faut le faire selon mme
efforts et l'autre partie siennes
logement et puis ensuite c'est
l'industrie industrie on l'a laissé
partir à l'étranger notre industrie on
va là rapatriés il faut qu'elle passe à
l'électricité et à l'hydrogène et donc
ça c'est un effort très important et je
ne suis pas sûr que on le conçoit
vraiment bien notamment donné le là vous
l'avez expliqué un effort à la fois
planifier et qui exige du temps long
[Musique]
l'europe nucléaire concerne aujourd'hui
13 pays sur 27 hormis la grande bretagne
des pays qui disposent de réacteurs
nucléaires la france représente 50% de
la production nucléaire de l'union
européenne production qui assure le
quart de l'électricité le camp anti
nucléaires pour schématiser sous la
houlette de l'allemagne et de l'autriche
est sensiblement équivalent en nombre de
pays
gageons que je vous pose cette situation
est elle appelée à se modifier et dans
quel sens brice lalonde
alors c'est qui va l'emporter est une
bataille parce que pour l'instant la
commission
européenne d'aller sur le modèle allez
on va consommer moins on va produire
moins de biomasse tout et des moins
c'est moins partout et évidemment la
commission émet même le gouvernement
français jusqu'à jusqu'au discours de
belfort excusez moi il y avait un fort
sentiment anti nucléaire c'était un peu
les idées reçues c'était la doxa un bon
et madame von der leyen et autres mais
elles sont quand même très proche des
idées avant moi je vois bien les projets
de directives de ce qu'on appelle le
fait pour fifty five 1 le programme de
décarbonation de l'europe c'est quand
même très très largement les idées
allemandes et chaque fois que je vois
dans les directives on travaille on
travaille là-dessus ya marqué on nous
l'a renouvelables renouvela jamais
décarbonés et alors donc nous on insiste
andy bischoff dire il faut mettre
décarbonés ce moment là le nucléaire à
sa place à non pour l'instant s'est pas
fait donc il ya une bataille voilà pour
l'instant dans l'europe c'est une
bataille
pronostics jacques percebois comment ça
va évoluer en europe c'est la question à
mon avis ceux qui ont du nucléaire les
13 pays qu'on du nucléaire vont
maintenir l'option nucléaire à
l'exception d'un pays l'allemagne qui va
sortir à la fin 2022 c'est sûr c'est
vraiment le pays qui se reprenait bien
ya un pays qui veut sortir mais qui a
bien changé d'avis au moins
provisoirement c'est la belgique
puisqu'il prolonge je dirais les
réacteurs
d'une dizaine d'années pour certains
d'entre eux ils n'excluent pas de sortir
il ya d'autres pays qui ont envisagé
sortir comme l'espagne comme la suède
mais c'est un peu je dirais je sors sans
vraiment sortir et je reverrai au cas où
parmi les pays qui n'ont pas nucléaire
il ya un pays qui veut en faire c'est la
pologne et pour les autres qui ont dû
nucléaire vont maintenir l'option il a
développé c'est notamment vrai sur les
pays de l'europe de l'est de l'europe de
l'union européenne donc ces pays-là
maintienne une option nucléaire est
d'ailleurs construisent pour certains
d'entre eux déjà des réacteurs
nucléaires supplémentaires les analystes
s'interrogent et les intérêts vous
comment vous voyez des avions est
forcément d'accord avec jacques
percebois je pense que en effet
l'allemagne sort c'est toujours dans un
coin de ma tête de new york c'est un
grand pays industriel et que certaines
générations vont vont passer le flambeau
à d'autres et que peut-être on en
reparlera dans quelques années mais en
tout cas à 10 ans ils sortent la pologne
rentrer avec une très grande motivation
parce que c'est un changement sociétal
considère à pau saharien à remplacer le
charbon quelques heures de leurs
économies de leur société en fait à 1,2
depuis des décennies par par le
nucléaire et les autres pays vont rester
à peu près stable
je dirais que j'ai un voeu en fait mais
qui est inquiète un peu un voeu pieux un
peu idéaliste en fait aujourd'hui ce
serait que un jour cette europe se
rendent compte que l'enjeu du changement
climatique est l'enjeu de sa
souveraineté dépassent très largement
c'est ces guerres tribales essais débats
tribales donc j'aimerais que le vrai
débat et que le vrai combat donc par le
brice lalonde ça soit un combat pour la
souveraineté politique énergétique
économique de l'europe est un combat
contre le changement climatique
ça alignerait beaucoup de choses et puis
j'ai envie de dire on va voir on va
aller au résultat vous savez dans la
politique énergétique allemande l'ana
agence blé qui vendent des agences de
l'environnement allemande a publié à
plusieurs reprises d évaluation de la
politique énergétique allemande en 2050
c'est un organisme indépendant qui n'est
pas spécialement pro-nucléaire
d'ailleurs au passage mais qui éclaire
un peu les choses qui a dit que dans les
sites à deux reprises à trois ans
d'intervalle que dans les scénarios
les plus d'écart bonnan pour l'allemagne
ça ne vous plaît pas et qu'il faudrait
qu'en 2050 l'allemagne export importe
significativement une énergie décarbonée
venant de pays limitrophes
voilà vous savez pas quelque part cette
ce constat de l' agence de
l'environnement allemande montre l'écart
entre le
le le discours vendus et la vraie vie
donc j'ai envie de dire sur la décennie
2030 qui à mon avis le contrôle de brice
lalonde est une décennie où les citoyens
vont avoir envie de résultats sur les
questions de changement climatique
on a pas on a on s'en est aperçu de cet
enjeu dans les années 90 2000 on en a
parlé dans les années 2010 je pense
qu'il y aura une vraie différence pour
les dirigeants entre ceux qui auront des
résultats et ceux qui n'en auront pas ou
alors il nous est aussi optimiste xavier
or ça c'est à dire que en phase avec eux
la nécessité
le résultat pourront faire changer la
prise âge célèbre partagent cet espoir
mais je voudrais pas complexifier le
débat mais je voudrais qu'à me rajoute
un petit bémol disant que parmi les pays
qui sont nucléaire qui vont le rester il
ya une deuxième dépendance et qu'à une
partie à l'est qui dépend du combustible
russe quand même et donc s'il y avait
quelques petits changements à faire
là-bas n'y a pas que les gens de l'est
puisque la suisse dépend à 80 peut
achète pour 80% de combustible russe
donc elle est pas dans l'europe donc oui
je partage cette je partage cette vision
nous le démontrer qu'on sait faire qu'on
sait produire une énergie
disponible encore au mieux je n'ai pas
vous prendre comme devin économique ni
même de vin dustrit yale mais quand même
aujourd'hui avec la guerre en ukraine la
pression sur le gaz est ce que vous
pensez que c'est une bonne chose pour le
nucléaire
je pense pas que la guerre c'est une
bonne chose on
ne parle pas de
voix que les prix d'uranium monte je
vois que les gens ce qu'il ya des gens
qui veulent stocker je vois qu'on se
préoccupe de 2,7 de cette énergie alors
que l était pas au sommet des
préoccupations de certains acteurs donc
effectivement c'est un effet
en effet si on peut dire positif de ce
côté là oui brice lalonde note en termes
géostratégiques
non mais en plus de ça je pense qu'il ya
une espèce de renaissance nucléaire un
peu partout et c'est très important la
france tout seul ne peut pas faire du
théâtre tout seul il faut qu'il y ait un
espèce d'environnement à la fois
culturel scientifique une espèce
d'émulation des recherches etc aux états
unis ça recommence les gens sont
intéressés alors évidemment il nous
disait c'est complètement nouveau le
nucléaire est complètement nouveau mais
on voit bien que qu' il ya de nouveau
des jeunes qui s'intéressent au
nucléaire alors qu'avant pendant
longtemps les jeunes les ingénieurs il
aller plus haut dans la forêt pas bon
non c'est très important le goût et
l'envié de dompter en quelque sorte les
éléments la nature des terrains et dans
et d'en faire quelque chose de bien ça
revient bon et alors il ya la chine il
ya beaucoup d'autres pays est là et
cette guerre est très malheureuse parce
que la russie est aussi un pays
nucléaire important trésor c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment regrettable de
cette erreur de poutine c'est terrifiant
quoi sur cette question-là de
souveraineté énergétique est ce qu'elle
est
l'idée revient aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous pensez que le conflit en ukraine
favorise si on peut dire d'une certaine
manière
la sécurité de l'approvisionnement
partir du nucléaire je pense oui mais
d'ailleurs ça va ça va même plus loin
parce que sur les 126 réacteurs actuels
qui sont en fonctionnement dans l'union
européenne une à 18 qui sont d'origine
soviétique ou russe est donc dans les
cinq pays qui sont la finlande ça doit
être la finlande la tchéquie la
slovaquie la hongrie et la bulgarie et
donc ces pays-là et une à métaux qui
sont en construction par les russes en
principe en hongrie et donc ces pays
s'interroge pour savoir s'ils vont
continuer à utiliser ce type de réacteur
et vers quels réacteurs il vont se se
tourner donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un
marché pour soi les chinois soient les
français soit rien et combien les
coréens ou les américains afin de nous
les japonais donc il ya un marché de est
alors grâce aux modifications
stratégiques alors sur la vérité des
coûts
concernant le nucléaire les
renouvelables si on interne à l'iss
qu'on appelle les coûts externes
c'est-à-dire pour le nucléaire les
déchets le démantèlement mais pour les
renouvelables intermittence où on en est
aujourd'hui
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut prévoir jacques
percebois alors l'étude de rte est très
intéressant d'inertie rte le réseau de
transport d'électricité a fait une étude
à l'horizon 2050 avec plusieurs
scénarios et le scénario qui
collectivement et le moins coûteux c'est
le scénario avec 50% nucléaire pourquoi
pourquoi les renouvelables le scénario
être beaucoup de renouvelables et plus
sont plus coûteux ces scénarios sont
plus coûteux parce qu'ils tiennent
compte de ce qu'on appelle les coûts
système c'est à dire les coûts liés à la
flexibilité pour dire les choses
autrement quand vous avez des énergies
intermittentes il faut prévoir du
stockage vous faut prévoir seulement
accueillir des centrales je dirais
qu'ils sont là pour prendre le relais et
par conséquent si vous tenez compte du
coût du stockage qui se fait soit par
des batteries soit en passant par
l'hydrogène à ce moment-là ça renchérit
le prix de revient alors c'est vrai que
pour les centrales thermiques par
exemple qui fonctionnent au charbon ou
au gaz
on tient compte du prix du carbone
aujourd'hui il ya un marché du co2 et ça
renchérit beaucoup d'ailleurs le prix de
revient du du mégawattheure qui est fait
avec des centrales thermiques classiques
pour le nucléaire il faut tenir compte
évidemment du coup du je dirais du
stockage des déchets mais pour les
renouvelables il faut pas oublier que
l'intermittence un coût pour le système
et par conséquent ce coût ce qu'on
appelle le coût complet doit tenir
compte de ces flexibilité et le scénario
vertueux montre bien que à partir du
moment où vous tenez compte de ces coûts
externes et bien le les renouvelables
j'irai le coût complet est relativement
élevé parce que 2 traditionnellement ne
tenait pas compte pour vous assurer
xavier ça que le coût du nucléaire
restera concurrentiel dans les années à
venir la production d'électricité à
partir du nucléaire oui par rapport à
vous savez ali aux renouvelables et
maintenant
on parle beaucoup d'hydrogène aussi et
pour moi ça repose sur trois piliers ça
repose sur le fait qu'on construise des
modèles qu'on que nous avons optimisé et
qui ont beau être des modèles de
troisième génération donc avec beaucoup
de dispositions pour la sûreté m'a
cherché à les optimiser pour gagner en
coûts premier point deuxième point
l'effet de série parce que quand vous
construisez des choses une par une bravo
lui construise des repères sur un même
site et vous allez voir on va en parler
vous avez évidemment un effet
industrielle dans la qualité le respect
du planning et la baisse des coûts et
puis la logique de financement ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure de manière tout à
fait évidente donc c'est en cumulant ces
trois aspects que nous arriverons à
avoir un nucléaire de troisième
génération qui est peut-être un petit
peu plus cher que le nucléaire deuxième
génération le parc existant et
finalement pas beaucoup plus cher et
donc nous arrivons à renouveler le parc
et engager la france dans une
trajectoire bar carbone sans faire
exploser des collectrices thé et c'est
ce que le rapport rt regarde c'est
intéressant parce que le rapport rte
c'est que vous disiez n'a pas cherché à
dire quel est le coût en euros par
mégawatt heure de chaque énergie met à
chercher à dire combien je dois investir
chaque année jusqu'en 2050 dans
différents scénarios pour avoir un
résultat bas carbone et c'est là qu'on
voit que le la trajectoire où on a
besoin de mettre le moins 2 milliards
d'euros sur la table chaque année c'est
quand ce sont quand même des milliards
d'euros chaque année pour l'état le coût
du combustible ne joue pas n'est ce pas
clos du liban tall il est pas
fondamental contrairement à ce qu'il est
pour les aider les grandes arbres dans
les scénarios ont été étudiés on tient
compte du recyclage qui est explicité
française et de la fin de vie des
déchets c'est vraiment une étude qui est
tout à fait holistique travail
remarquable
[Musique]
vous voyez on parlait des faits de série
marcel boiteux qui fut un légendaire
président d'edf montre l intérêt de
l'effet de série et d'évoquer les faits
de série mais d'ailleurs cet effet de
serre y joue pour les innovations et
également sur la croissance comme l'a
montré le prix nobel et demi fait mais à
cela s'ajoute la recherche et de
développement et ça va nous donner
l'occasion de parler
des nouvelles technologies de ce que
peut faire la filière nucléaire et
l'industrie à l'avenir
quels sont les progrès actuels sur les
nouveaux br / les petits réacteurs res
mrs qui a l'a vraiment des percées
technologiques qui se prépare et qui
sont en cours nous avions oui alors un
différend de différents ordres je dirais
sur les nouveaux repères là il ya des ya
des surnoms que je perds 2 par rapport
aux pairs il ya des évolutions sur le
caractère industriel du modèle lingerie
dit un effet de serre est beaucoup plus
important entre eux mais également à
l'intérieur du réacteur où on a tous
standardisés pour avoir un effet de
serre idée des composants vous mettez à
l'inter du recteur il y à de nouvelles
méthodes de construction qui vont nous
faire gagner de l'argent et qui sont
très innovante est probablement la plus
grande innovation c'est qu'en fait le
recteur repères de ses réacteurs
numérique à la base c'est à dire il a
été conçu numériquement depuis le début
et il a son jumeau numérique qui va nous
aider à le construire acheter les pièces
à évaluer sa son vieillissement à
simuler les opérations de maintenance
donc je dirais en même temps qu'on
construit le réacteur béton et métal
j'ai envie de faire y aura il ya le
réacteur numérique qui existe depuis le
début sur les smr on est sur des
réacteurs de plus petite taille le
produit que nous développons aujourd'hui
s'appelle new world c'est
fondamentalement un réacteur de
troisième génération à eau pressurisée
mais là l'idée c'est de dire je ne fais
pas la course vers plus de puissance
pour gagner en coup je fais là je prends
plus petit mais je vais essayer d'en
faire des dizaines à cette fois ci c'est
pas si c'est pas 8 c'est pas 14 ne sait
même pas 30 c'est des dizaines qu'il
faudra faire dans plusieurs pays à
l'identique et donc je vais construire
des 18 in à fabriquer des modules qui
vont rendre moins cher le smr alors
c'est une promesse intéressante c'est
l'innovation majeure elle a un défi clé
c est ce que nous allons arriver à faire
adopter le même modèle par plusieurs
autorités de sûreté strictement à
l'identique et si nous y arrivons et
jeux de bons espoirs au moins à
l'échelle européenne alors le smr est
intéressant et puis ensuite il ya des
réflexions sur des réacteurs plus
avancés dont on peut dont on pleure ses
réacteurs portables dits petits
réacteurs et services portable
est
vrai jacques percebois qu'on a du retard
par rapport à des pays comme les
etats-unis la chine ou la russie à bas
le pays qui est le plus avancé c'est la
russie 1 mais d'autres pays seront sont
également bien en avance la chine or la
france essaye de rattraper ce retard on
a peut-être pris un peu de retard en est
faux départ mais les deux projets niaux
enfin les deux réacteurs une fois rld du
projet new world font qu'on rattrape ce
retard ces temps je crois que les pires
acteurs ils ont pas vocation à remplacer
les opel espère d'autres choses
deviennent claires ils ont vocation
essentiellement à être exporté c'est à
dire à remplacer pour faire simple des
centrales à charbon dans d'autres pays
c'est ça l'objectif en france ils auront
un rôle relativement marginal oui mais
au niveau des territoires ça peut être
utile oui au niveau des territoires où
surtout à l'exportation quand vous êtes
à 170 mégawatts vous êtes quasiment dix
fois moins qu'une puissance dix fois
moindre que celle d'anne périmés sur un
territoire inaccessible sa peau sèche ou
difficilement accessibles
ça peut permettre plus facilement
importer l'électricité n'ont
certainement mais il faut aussi trouver
les sites un faux pas perdre de vue que
trouver des sites pour le nucléaire
c'est pas facile construire des
réacteurs low des sites existants c'est
possible trouver de nouveaux sites pour
des réacteurs c'est compliqué alors
brice lalonde vous avez été ministre de
l'environnement je n'ai pas faire un
procès de votre action mais je voudrais
vous poser cette question
la france a anticipé sur la question des
déchets avec un réacteur de quatrième
génération qui s'appelait astrid
finalement avec astrid ont diminué le
volume des déchets de très haute
toxicité et de très longue durée est-ce
qu'on a eu tort d'arrêter astrid ds qui
pour reprendre astrid alors
c'est une caisse une question difficile
parce que astrid ne diminuer les déchets
que comme une cerise sur le gâteau en
plus de la production d'électricité pour
laquelle elle était quand même conçu
mais donc moi je jeu se défend une autre
voie qui est celle de deux réacteurs
conçus spécifiquement pour détruire les
déchets de longues périodes et je
soutiens à cet égard ce qui se passe en
belgique c'est assez curieux la belgique
voulait arrêter le nucléaire mais elle
ne voulait pas arrêter son expérience
qui s'appelle mira qui est un réacteur à
neutrons rapides parce qu'ils pour
casser les actinides ces atomes de
longue durée qu'il faut de l'énergie et
donc
c'est un réacteur plan bismuth donc
une autre technique si vous voulez moi
je me méfie je ne sais pas parce que là
vous avez en effet une fantastique
renaissance des innovations des
recherches alliés des différents modèles
la quatrième génération maintenant à la
mode c'est le sel fondu et vous avez des
petits réacteurs à des gens qui viennent
en dix ans et des startups mois on a un
modèle extraordinaire
tranquille n'allons pas trop vite si
l'on doit à quoi ça sert et si vous fait
les petits réacteurs si vous voulez il
faut 1 c'est complètement différent il
faut être service après-vente absolument
considérable avec des gens qui viennent
se m'occupe du combustible mox vous dès
que vous dérangez pas je m'occupe des
déchets on va les mettre ça va faire des
transports c'est compliqué c'est pas
fait encore un s'est pas fait donc
travaillons doucement en plus on a la
fusion qu'il va en parler tous derrière
donc sous les déchets c'est très très
important moi je pense qu on a
maintenant avec le progrès des
techniques nucléaires on sait comment
raccourcir la durée de vie des déchets
de longue période ça coûte cher donc
pour l'instant le fait pas parce qu'on
se dit
avec ben hur avec murs ellaone enfoui
des déchets avec l'enfouissement ça
devrait ça devrait coller mais moi je
dis avec la transmutation si vous cassez
alors vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique et
que vous avez indiquée a complètement
nouveau complètement acceptable comprend
10 maury là-dessus premièrement je suis
assez bien monsieur ministre mais
premièrement joder cas france est un des
rares pays qui s'est posé le problème
des déchets on peut dire que c'est pas
suffisant et c'est s'est posé le
problème des chaînes de deux manières
d'abord elle a fait le choix du
recyclage pour diminuer les déchets et
transformer quelque part des déchets en
combustible aujourd'hui 10% du duvet
tricité couru mais avec as mais il y en
avait moins et elle aurait déjà
10% de deux laiteries cité est fait à
partir de déchets recyclés il ya des
travaux de recherche c'est pas ça
aboutira pour porter ce 10 à 30 par le
multi recyclage etc etc bon c'est un jeu
c'est un point de divergence avec le
sait la lande mais après sur le sujet
des réacteurs de nouvelle génération
xi orsay a parlé des smr est le projet
de ward est absolument passionnant il ya
comme le disait brice lalonde il ya un
foisonnement d'idées mais autour de ses
idées il faut pas tout jeter parce que
je pense que notamment les réacteurs à
sels fondus peuvent avoir leurs intérêts
peut-être pas d'ailleurs
majoritairement pour faire de
l'électricité mais pour encore une fois
diminuer la durée de vie de certains
déchets de l'acte i need et aussi pour
faire de la chaleur pourquoi pas on
pourra utiliser directement la chaleur
sans passer par le cycle de carnot et on
aura un rendement excellent et pourquoi
écarter cela fait partie de la solution
aussi alors nous avions ça n'arrive la
fin de cette émission le temps écoulé
l'a peut-être pour faire rêver les
téléspectateurs
un nucléaire sans déchets radioactifs
évidemment ça rendrait le nucléaire
pérenne sur le très très long terme pour
y accéder il faudrait passer de la
fission à la fusion il ya une actualité
de la fusion ou sané cas
rêve finalement je pense n'est pas qu'un
rêve il ya une véritable actualité de la
fusion dans des dons des réacteurs de
recherche pour le moment et puis demain
une échelle vous pourrez dire industriel
avec iter un qui est un projet
absolument passionnant après c'est
difficile de dire à partir de quand cela
pourrait se concrétiser dans des dents
dans de vrais acteurs industriels donc
je pense que c'est un une cible qu'il
faut qu'on est en tête il reste réaliste
que je pense réaliste oui mais ça prend
aux banquiers qui est qui qui c'est
réaliste si on parle de durée très
longue c'est à dire de la fin de ce
siècle voilà avant il n'est pas prêt
scientifiquement on a énormément on a
énormément de choses d'abord il va
falloir maîtriser cette réaction malgré
tout et donc on a besoin d'expérience
pour arriver à la comprendre et à bien
la maîtriser on aura quand on passera à
l'échelle de d'industriels toutes sortes
de questions de matériaux qui devront
être qu'ils devront être résolus donc on
a on en a on a travaillé cela mais direz
vous voyez c'est intéressant je trouve
tout ce débat sur le nucléaire je me dis
ça ça dit quelque chose sur notre
rapport au monde qui nous entoure et sur
notre rapport à la science
moi je crois que le vrai sujet que nous
avons pour les 30 ans qui viennent c'est
le sujet de la lutte contre le
changement climatique d'un sujet la
lutte contre le changement climatique la
fusion n'apportera rien elle arrivera de
toute façon trop tard donc notre sujet
c'est d'avoir des réacteurs à fission
aux côtés de renouvelables qui sont là
vite équidés carbone et faire confiance
aux industriels et aux scientifiques qui
ont été capables d'aller chercher c'est
c'est cette énergie pour reprendre une
phrase dans des tableaux qui hélas de
nietzsche sous les jupes de la nature ça
a été trouvé c'est à dire c'est nick
n'ai pas connaissance de l'énergie
nucléaire mais il parle des
scientifiques qui vont chercher des
choses sous les jupes de la nature terre
ce que ce qui ne se voit pas
spontanément quand on regarde le soleil
levant où les vagues bien le nucléaire
c'est cela et je crois qu'être capable
au moment où on a un défi considérable
la lutte contre le changement climatique
d'exploiter ce qui sort de
l'intelligence humaine pour moi c'est
positif mais en effet ça la réaction
vis-à-vis du nucléaire dit sans doute
quelque chose sur notre rapport chacun
d'entre nous est collectivement à la
science bah écoute si vous voulez bien
on va se tenir à cette conclusion je
voudrais vous présenter une
bibliographie alors je commencerai par
le livre
jean-pierre en scène et ja percebois
transition électrique ce que l'europe et
les marchés n'ont pas su vous dire
que vous vous dites
pourquoi les marchés cherchent à cacher
des choses ja personnel marchés ne
prennent pas en compte justement les
questions de long terme qui ne peuvent
être prises en compte qu'à travers une
planification dire des choix étatique de
long terme très bien brice lalonde
vous venez de publier
excusez moi de vous déranger aux
éditions loeb
caisse
pourquoi cette expression excusez moi de
vous déranger vous cherchez vous dérange
et qui finalement élevé quand j'ai
commencé à écrire ses livres à l'époque
c'était encore
les sentiments anti nucléaire aussi aux
iem anti-science d'une grande partie de
des jeunes et notamment de ceux qui se
prétendent ou qui se disent écologistes
et donc je leur ai dit attention vous
attendent vous vous êtes en train de
vous tromper vous vous êtes vous montre
ça c'est les années 70 c'est fini
maintenant nous sommes dans deux mille
et quelques nous avons la lutte contre
le changement climatique
la grue une grande partie ou la totalité
du logiciel même écologistes des années
70 il faut l'abandonner il faut passer à
autre chose mais brice lalonde sur le
plan comme ça de l'intimité
intellectuelle qu'est ce qui vous a fait
changer d'avis sur le nucléaire c'est le
rapport du giec en 88 en 1988 ça a été
un été extraordinairement chaud monsieur
en scène un gant un climatologue
américain est venu témoigner devant
devant le sénat américain c'est je suis
devenu ministre me connaissez très bien
al gore et 188 madame thatcher
convaincre monsieur reagan d'accepter la
création du giec et le jex a fait ça
faisait deux ans que je suis à peu près
les débats les excès attention le
changement climatique c'est ce qui est
plus grave donc 6 6 4 plus grave c'est
beaucoup plus grave que le danger
nucléaire très bien merci de cette
confession si on peut dire je voudrais
signaler le livre d'alexandra bennoo
zimoun et sur la fusion nucléaire c'est
d'un point de vue scientifique et le
livre de pierre audigier nucléaire la
grande méprise des anti nucléaires
voilà il me reste à vous remercier
messieurs d'avoir participé à cette
émission sur le nucléaire en france et
en europe et je remercie l'équipe dès le
cp qui a permis la réalisation de cette
émission et avant de nous quitter je
vous soumet cette citation du grand
architecte anglais norman foster
le nucléaire est de loin l'énergie la
plus propre c'est dans laquelle nous
devons croire
[Musique]